[موسيقى]
بدات حياتها بين الهندسه المعماريه
والقانون فجاه صارت رسالتها حق بلادها
وبلدها وهاجسها اعاده اعماره انتقلت مهنيا
الى تحرير نصوص للمسرح والفن فصارت في قلب
معركه وطنها وشعبها اعتقدت ذات يوم انها
تزوجت بطلا مسرحيا يصفق له بعض جمهور في
اخر العرض فصارت ذات يوم شريكه رئيس بلدي
حرب يصفق له رؤساء وزعماء العالم كيف
انقلبت حياتها في سنه وكيف تتكيف مع هذا
الانقلاب بعد سنه من الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ماذا تقول عن اول سنه من هذه
الحرب المدمره على اوكرانيا وعن اوكرانيا
في السنوات المقبله ضيفت الليل مشاهدينا
بمناسبه الذكرى السنويه للحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه طيفه مميزه هي السي لاوكرانيا
اوليناسكي السيده الاولى اولينا اليوم
يصادف مرور سنه على الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه دمار خراب تشريد للعائلات
الاوكرانيه يعني حاله اوكرانيا لا يمكن
وصفها بكلمات مع مرور سنه على هذه الحرب
كيف يمكن تلخيص هذه السنه امجاج
طبعا هذه السنه سنه الاختبارات الشديده لا
احد من الاوكرانيين يرفض ان يعيش هذه
السنه في سلام وهذه السنه قد اردنا مدى
صمودنا ومدى الصمود جنودنا الذين يحفظوننا
ومضى صمود مجتمعنا ومدى قوه اقتصادنا
والتجاره التي ما زالت مستمره في بعض
الاحيان عندما تمشي في كييف لا شيء سوى
حواجز الطرق والتفتيش التي تذكرك بان هناك
حربا جاريه وهذا امر غريب حقا لان المجتمع
يحاول ان يعيش ويحاول البقاء على قيد هذا
ما اظهره لنا هذا العام نحن مرنون نحن
اقوياء يمكننا مواجهه اي تحديات ونؤمن
بالنصر
كرهبه
قبل سنوات قليله لم يعني لم تكوني تتصورين
ولا العالم يتصور انك ستكونين السيده
الاولى للحرب اتحدث ليس فقط السيده الاولى
لاوكرانيا اليوم بعد مرور سنه ما الذي
تغير اساسيا باولينا
حسنا اولا وقبل كل شيء سابدا بحقيقه ان لا
احد يجهزك على الاطلاق كيف تكونين سيده
اولى خصوصا في حاله الحرب ولا احد يجهزك
لحقيقه انه يجب ان تكونين زوجه رئيس دوله
في حاله حرب ولكن كما قال داروين ليس
الاسرع او الاقوى من ينجو ولكن اولئك
الذين يمكنهم
لذلك اعتقد انني اعمل وفق متطلبات العصر
حسب مقتضيات الظروف التي نعيش فيها احاول
ان افعل كل ما يجب علي من اجل تقريب
انتصارنا والشيء الاكثر اهميه هو التحدث
عن اوكرانيا عن الاوكرانيين في اي منصه
حيث اتيحت للفرصه للتحدث لذا اشكركم مره
اخرى على هذه المقابله للعالم العربي انا
حقا اريدك ان تسمعنا اعلم ان لدينا قيمًا
مشتركه وستفهموننا ستفهمون مشاعرنا اننا
ندافع عن انفسنا ونحمي مستقبلنا وحياه
اطفالنا هذه هي المشاعر الوحيده التي توحد
الاوكرانيين الان نريد ان نعيش ولهذا
السبب نرى مثل هذا الصراع الرهيب والصعب
لذلك انا لا افصل دوري عن دوري جميع
الاوكرانيين الاخرين انا اتصرف كما سيتصرف
الجميع في مكاني
كيف اثرت هذه الحرب طبعا هي اثرت على
الجميع ولكن اتحدث عن زوجك كانسان وعن
اولادك كطفال وليس كرئيس
وكاطفال او اولاد رئيس
لا اعتقد ان هذه حياه طبيعيه نعيش بعيدا
عن بعضنا البعض لمده عام تقريبا الان في
الواقع هذا اختبار لعائلتنا اختبار صعب
لكنني متاكده اننا سوف نجتازه لديه القوه
لخوض هذه الفتره واثق بقدراته وبلده لذلك
سينجح في كل هذا اتمنى له الصحه والقوه
فقط نفكر جميعا في شيء واحد فقط متى تنتهي
الحرب ومتى تبدا الحياه الطبيعيه لان هذا
العام لا يمكن ان يسمى حياه طبيعيه نحن
منفصلون يمكنني رؤيته عده مرات في الاسبوع
ونادرا ما يراه الاطفال للاسف لكننا نامل
جميعا في الافضل
قبل ان انتقل الى الناحيه يعني ماذا تفعل
نساء اوكرانيا اليوم وكيف تدعمين القضيه
الاوكرانيه في الداخل وفي الخارج هل يمكن
ان نتحدث الى العالم العربي عن اللحظات
الاولى من هذه الحرب ما الذي حدث حدث داخل
العائله الاوكرانيه داخل عائلتكم اتحدث
عنك وعن الرئيس والاولاد كيف تحدثتم مع
بعض واخذتم القرار بالمواجهه
لقد كنا نتذكر باستمرار هذا اليوم الرهيب
لمده عام لم يكن الشعور الاول مفاجئا ولم
يفاجئ احد لقد كان شعورا بالصدمه لانهم
فعلوا ذلك فعلا فعلوا شيئا لم يكن ينبغي
فعله لم يكن هذا منطقيا ولم يتم استفزازه
لقد هجموا علينا حقا من جميع الجهات في
الصباح البا وكان اصعب شيء بالنسبه لي هو
كيف اقول للاطفال كان علي ان اذهب الى
الغرفه واوقظهم واخبرهم بان الحرب قد بدات
لكن لحسن الحظ لقد استيقظوا بالفعل وفهموا
بالفعل كل شيء لم يكن علي ان اخبرهم باي
شيء ومنذ تلك اللحظه بدا زمن فيصل عائلتنا
بعد ذلك لم يروا والدهم الا بعد بضعه اشهر
اليوم اكثر من اي وقت مضى نتذكر ذلك
التاريخ لا يوجد تاريخ انتهاء لهذه الحرب
لكن لها تاريخ بدء وكان ذلك في الربع
والعشرين من فبراير من العام الماضي وسوف
نتذكر دائما هذا اليوم الرهيب
هناك سؤال اساسي اليوم لدى كل جمهور
العالم العربي والعالم اجمع الكل يعلم
فارق القوه الكبير بين الجيشين الاوكراني
والروسي
لم يتصور احد ان يتجرا رئيس دوله ان كان
اوكرانيا او غير اوكرانيا ان يقف ويواجه
بوتين ما الذي جعله يكون واثق من انه قادر
على مواجهه الجيش الروسي
نحن جميعا مدفعون بمشاعر بسيطه للغايه
نريد فقط ان نعيش ونريد ان نعيش في بلدنا
ولنا حق في ذلك لذلك لا يمكنني فصل قرار
الرئيس عن قرار المواطنين الاخرين في
اوكرانيا فقد كان ذلك قرار الشعب
الاوكراني المقاومه الدفاع لقد استوفى
الرئيس ارادتهم فقط لكنها كانت ايضا
مشاعره الداخليه ومن ناحيه اخرى من سنكون
اذا لم ندافع عن انفسنا هذا شعور بقيمه
الذات لا يمكننا ان نفعل غير ذلك ونحن
نواصل القيام بذلك الان
الجانب الاخر من هذه الحرب بجانب يعني
الرجال اليوم موجودين بالميدان يقاتلون
بالسياسه
بالاسلحه بكل شيء ولكن هناك جانب اخر كان
ملفت جدا بالنسبه للعالم اجمع منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب هي المراه الاوكرانيه اذا اردت
اليوم ان تتحدثين عن دور المراه
الاوكرانيه بهذه الحرب وما الذي واجهته
وشاهدته منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وحتى هذه
الساعه
لن افرد النساء من المجتمع الاوكراني على
الاطلاق لان لدينا نساء في كل مكان بدءا
من حقيقه وجود نساء في الجيش وانتهاء
بحقيقه وجود نساء في جميع مجالات الحياه
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه هذه حرب لكل
اوكرانيا يمكن تسميه النساء الاوكرانيات
باللاجئات حيث اخذت ملايين النساء اطفالهن
الى الخارج
ممتنون لتلك البلدان التي قبلت الهجره
القسريه لدينا لقد انقذوهم بكل ما تحمله
الكلمه من معنى كما ان الملايين من النساء
الاوكرانيات يبقينا هنا ويواصلنا العمل
لان معظم من يقومون بالتدريس من النساء
نريد ان يتعلم اطفالنا هذا هو مستقبلنا
الغالبيه العظمى من الاطباء هم ايضا من
النساء وهن ايضا يقاومنا ويعملنا ايضا
لانقاذ شعبنا كل يوم هذا عمل شاق جدا لذلك
يبدو لي انه اذا كنت سترسم وجه المقاومه
الاوكرانيه فان هذا الوجه سيكون نصف انثى
ونصف ذكر وبنسب متساويه لا اريد ان اخصص
المراه في لحظه نضالنا وبعدها عندما ياتي
انتصارنا سيكون كل منا معنا مجتمعنا موحد
ويتكون من جزئين متساويين ذكر وانثى
مقابل النساء هناك ايضا اطفال اوكرانيا
اطفال اوكرانيا عانوا كثيرا منذ بدايه
الحرب وحتى هذه الساعه هناك الكثير منهم
يتامى الكثير منهم مشردين تحدث عن تفكك
العائلات يعني انت ايضا معنيه بهذا الملف
بشكل اساسي لانك تهتمين باطفال اوكرانيا
اليوم ما الذي فعلتيه منذ اللحظه الاولى
لكي لتخفيف التروما التي قد تؤثر على
الجيل المستقبل لاوكرانيا
انها واحده من اكثر الجروح الى من التي
نعاني منها بشكل عام لم نتوقع مدى وحشيه
الحرب من جانب روسيا طبعا الحرب مخيفه
دائما لكن الاساليب التي يديرونها بها
وهذه الفظاعه ببساطه لا يمكن وصفها
بالكلمات وبالفعل فان هذا الوضع هو الاكثر
خطوره على الاطفال حتى الان مات اكثر من
450 طفلا هذا رقم رهيب ما يقرب من ضعف هذا
العدد مصابون ومشوهون وبالفعل هناك مثل
هذه الجروح التي احدثتها الحرب والتي
ستعطي علامات بعد سنوات او حتى عقود هذه
اصابات نفسيه لا شيء يمكن مقارنته عندما
راى الطفل وفاه والديه بعينيه او لدينا
حالات تم فيها اخراج طفل من سياره اطلقت
النار عليها ومات والداه وحرق هناك والطفل
بقي على قيد الحياه باعجوبه كيف سيعيش مع
هذا لذلك نحاول اخماد هذه الحرائق الان
ونحاول ان نكون مستعدين مسبقا لمساعده
هؤلاء الاطفال الذين يعانون من مثل هذه
الاصابات الحاده نحن نعمل على تطوير
برنامج للصحه العقليه لجميع الاوكرانيين
حيث تكون رعايه هؤلاء الاطفال واعاده
تاهيلهم وعلاجهم نقطه منفصله اذا كنا
نتحدث عن الاطفال الذين على سبيل المثال
فقد والديهم والذين اصبحوا ايتاما فهذا
ايضا مجال منفصل لنشاط على وجه الخصوص
تساعد مؤسسه الان دور الايتام العائليه
عندما تستقبل الاسره من خمسه الى عشره
اطفال لتنشاتهم ونحن نعلم الان ان دعم هذه
العائلات مهم جدا لكل طفل الحق في ان يكون
له منزل ولا نريد ان ينتهي المطاف
باطفالنا الذين تيتموا خلال الحرب في دور
الايتام والمدارس الداخليه شرعت اوكرانيا
في طريق التخلي عن اشكال التعليم مثل هذا
هذا ايضا احد شروطنا للانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتحاول مؤسسه دعم هذا المسار على
وجه التحديد من خلال دعم هذه الاسره
الحاضنه الجديده دعما لعمليه التبني
باكملها الهدف هو عدم وجود اي طفل في
اوكرانيا يعيش في دار للايتام بحيث تكون
لديه اسره كل من الدوله ونحن شخصيا
وغالبيه الشخصيات العامه كثيرون يهتمون
بهذه الق ضيه اذ جاف
بخاطري
انت ايضا لديك اطفال اطفالك اليوم هل
يعانون تروما الحرب وكيف تخففين عنهم هذا
الموضوع
كام احاول ان اجعل هذه الفتره طبيعيه قدر
الامكان لكن هذا ليس ممكنا دائما عندما
انظر اليهم من هذا الجانب يبدو كانهم
اوقفوا حياتهم هذا يعني انه لا يوجد طفل
الان في اوكرانيا واولادي ليسوا استثناء
ولا يمكنهم ان يحلموا بحريه ويضعوا خططهم
الخاصه لانهم لا يعرفون ماذا سيحدث لهم
غدا مهمتنا الان كاباء هي خلق مثل هذه
الظروف حتى يستمر الاطفال في التعلم
ويعتقدون اننا سنعود الى الحياه الطبيعيه
كام احاول قدر المستطاع ان افعل ذلك
لاطفالي لكن من المؤلم حقا ان يتخلى طفلك
على سبيل المثال عما كان يحبه من قبل كان
ابني يشارك في الرقصات الشعبيه وفي العام
الماضي احب الذهاب الى الفريق ورقص على
الرقصات الشعبيه الاوكرانيه والان اردت
اقناعه بالعوده لكنه يرفض قائلا هل
يساعدني الرقص في حمايتك كل ما يف فيه
الان هو نوع من الرياضه القتال اليدوي
السلاح نعم هذه سمه لجميع اطفالنا الان
لكننا لم نربهم من اجل ذلك بل قمنا
بتربيتهم من اجل السلام وهذا هو السبب في
صعوبه مشاهدتهم يخسرون كل هذه الاشهر امل
حقا ان يتمكنوا من العوده الى الموسيقى
والرقص وتعلم اللغات وليس فقط التفكير في
الحرب
انا تلك
الكلمه الاولى التي قلتها للرئيس زيننسكي
فورا وقوع الحرب او الجمله الاولى ماذا
كانت هل تذكرينه
اتذكروا انني كنت مرتبكه كان الوقت مبكرا
جدا وكان لا يزال مظلما سالت زوجي ما هذا
سمعت دوي في جارات بالفعل كانت هذه اصواتا
غير مالوفه لنا قال لي كلمه واحده لقد
بدات انا فهمت كل شيء
منذ بدايه الحرب الرئيسي لينسكي هو الهدف
الاول
للرئيس الروسي ولهذه الحرب لاغتياله اتحدث
عن اغتيال جسديا وليس فقط معنويا بالحرب
انتم الهدف الثاني هل رسبتم اي محاولات
اغتيال بالفتره الماضيه لك وللاطفال
يقولون انهم قد حاولوا اذا فكرت في الامر
فسيكون من المخيف ان تعيش احاول ان لا
افكر اكتشفت ذلك لاحقا انه كانت هناك
محاولات مزعومه ومن الجيد انني اكتشفت ذلك
لاحقا لانني كنت خائفه
الوجه الاخر لهذه الحرب هو الحرب الثقافيه
وانت يعني قمت
بدبلوماسيه الثقافيه منذ هذه الحرب اتحدث
هنا عن استعمال الدبلوماسيه ثقافيه
لدعم القضيه الاوكرانيه في الخارج الى اي
مدى ساهمت بدعم موقف اوكرانيا في كل
العالم
موجودين
يجب ان اعترف انني افعل ما اعتقد به فقط
ولهذا اعتقد حقا انه يساعد بالاضافه الى
جبهه الحرب لدينا جبهات عديده اخرى
الاقتصاديه بما في ذلك الجبهه الثقافيه
لسوء الحظ استحوذت روسيا على اشياء كثيره
من الثقافه الاوكرانيه لعده قرون خلال
الاتحاد السوفيتي خلال الامبراطوريه
الروسيه تم اخذ القطع الاثريه وتدمير
الوثائق التاريخيه حان الوقت الان لاعاده
الثقافه والتاريخ للاوكرانيين الحقيقيين
واظهارهما للعالم وهذا هو سبب وجود الكثير
من العمل الذي يتعين علينا القيام به على
هذه الجبهه لحسن الحظ نحن نفتح اعيننا
بالفعل على حقيقه ان الفنانين المعروفين
ارخب كونسي وايفازوفسكي الذين كان يعدان
دائما فنانين روسيين هما في الواقع
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
كيف يمكن وصف وضع الاوكرانيين اليوم
بالخرج نتحدث عن ملايين العائلات الذين
هجروا من اوكرانيا خصوصا ان دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذين كانت الوجهه الاولى لهم
تعاني اليوم من ازمات اقتصاديه غير قادره
حتى على تلبيه رغبه شعبه بهذا التوقيت
بذات
جاكو
اولا اود ان اشكر جميع البلدان التي قبلت
مهاجرين قصرا والموقف تجاههم في كل مكان
تقريبا دافئ جدا ويتم استقبالهم بكرامه
ولديهم فرصه للعمل ويمكن للاطفال الذهاب
الى المدرسه نحن ممتنون حقا لذلك نحن نعلم
ان هناك ازمه اقتصاديه في العديد من الدول
الاوروبيه ومن الممكن ان تكون مرتبطه
بالحرب في اوكرانيا لكن هذه فقط نتائج
العدوان الروسيه نتحدث عنها طوال الوقت
ليس بسبب اوكرانيا بل هذا بسبب روسيا انها
تضغط علينا بالسلاح وتضغط عليهم عالميا
واقتصاديا وتشعل نقاط عدوان جديده في دول
مختلفه وبين شعوب مختلفه لكن شعبنا يشعر
بانه طبيعي هناك وانا متاكده انهم يعاملون
بشكل جيد لو كان غير ذلك فاعتقد ان المزيد
من الناس سيعودون لقد عاد الكثير بالفعل
ولكن ليس كلهم ما زال عده ملايين من
الاشخاص في الخارج نحن ننتظر عودتهم
نجحت بالمهمه الاولى مع زوجك عندما كنت
كاتبه ومعده معه بالعمل الفني والمسرحي
واليوم تنجحين بشكل كبير كسيده اولى هل
يعني وجودك الى جانب الرئيس اليوم هو
القوه الاولى
بالمواجهه
الشمال لا انا لا اعتقد ذلك يبدو لي اننا
ندفع بعضنا البعض ونقوي بعضنا البعض نحن
محظوظان لاننا لسنا زوجين فقط بل صديقان
وشريكان ايضا نحن نف بعضنا البعض افهم
لماذا اتحدث على الجبهه الدبلوماسيه الان
انا افهم ذلك تماما ولدت بالعام 78 ونشات
يعني بظل سنوات قليله بوجود اوكرانيا
بالاتحاد السوفيتي ما الذي تذكرينه عن هذه
الفتره وهل كان لدى اهلك او لديك او في
المنزل الهويه الاوكرانيه البحث ام انها
نشات بعد التسعينات
انت محقه لقد عشت في منطقه تتحدث الروسيه
بشكل حصري تقريبا ولكن بصرف النظر عن ذلك
كانت اللغه الاوكرانيه موجوده وكانت
موجوده في كل مكان ودرسناها في المدرسه
واعتبرناها لغتنا الام عائلتي من جهه
والده تتحدث الروسيه اكثر وعائلتي من جهه
والدي تتحدث الاوكرانيه في المنزل اتذكر
ان جدتي كانت تحفظ تقريبا شعر شفت شينكو
لقد فوجئت كيف تذكرت كل هذا كانت تحب الاد
الاوكراني بشكل عام
كيف عشت الانتقال من الحقبه السوفيتيه الى
الحقبه الاوكرانيه ما الذي تذكرينه من هذه
تشدوه
الممتاز كنا مراهقين تصورنا كل هذا كوفر
جديده وحياه جديده كنا فخورين بالعيش في
دوله حره ومستقله وهذا هو السبب في انه
يؤلمنا كثيرا حتى ان نفكر اننا قد نخسرها
30 عاما من الاستقلال هذه ليست خمس سنوات
ولا سنتين لقد نشا جيل من الناس بالفعل
وعاش في اوكرانيا المستقله
الصوت النساء بالحرب الاوكرانيه والوجود
النسائي هو عنصر نجاح اساسي اليوم بكل
الراي يعني لكل الراي العام العالمي بظل
كل ما يجري بهذه الحرب الصوت النسائي
الروسي غائب لماذا برايك وماذا تقولين
لنساء وامهات روسيا بهذه الحرب هذا
مخيفه حتى في بدايه الحرب حاولنا الوصول
الى الامهات من روسيا لقد حاولنا اخبارهن
بانهن لا يفهمن ان هذه حرب مروعه وان
اطفالهن سيموتون بلا سبب لكنهن استمرنا في
ارسال اطفالهن للموت في بلد اجنبي لكنك
على حق نحن لا نسمع ايضا ونحن لا نرى في
بعض الاحيان فقط تتحدث اصوات منفرده ضد
الحرب وهذا مفاجئ في احسن الاحوال اود ان
اقتبس من اورويل انهم خائفون من العجز
العقلي الكامل لكن هذا في احسن الاحوال في
الواقع يدعم معظم الروس الحرب وهو امر
مخيف
رشيد
انت السيده الاولى التي تتحدث امام
الكونجرس الامريكي وكان خطاب مهم جدا في
تاريخ الكونغرس الامريكي وفي العالم هل
برايك الاهتمام اليوم من قبل دول الغرب هو
نا فقط من اهتمام بقضيه الشعب الاوكراني
ام لحسابات سياسيه غربيه ايضا دائما تتحدث
عنها روسيا وهي الحرب الامريكيه على ارض
اوكرانيا
انا متاكده من انها كانت بادره صداقه ودعم
صادقه حقا لانه في تلك المرحله لم يكن من
الممكن التحدث عن اي مغازله بين هذين
البلدين رايت عيون الناس الذين استمعوا
اليه في المؤتمر رايت انهم لم يستمعوا لي
فحسب بل شعروا بنا ايضا وكانت الدعوه
الصادقه والشعوري مما قلته ومدى ادراكهم
لي كان ايضا صادقا فهمنا بعضنا البعض شعرت
بالدعم هناك شير
رزم
الروس اليوم سيبقون الجار لاوكرانيا بحكم
الجغرافيا كيف
تتعاملون مع هذا الموضوع وتتعايشون معه
للفتره المقبله حتى بظل وما بعد الحرب هل
المشكله وهل المشكله اليوم هي مع الحكم مع
شخص بوتين ام مع روسيا ككل امسكه
الله
هذه هي مشكله معقده لكن الحكومه تؤثر على
السكان لذلك سيتوقف الكثير على الحكومه
التي ستحكم روسيا في المستقبل نعم لا
يمكننا الانتقال الى جزء اخر من العالم
واختيار جار ودود للاسف ولكن لكي نكون
اكثر هدوءا لبلدنا اقترح الرئيس زيلينسكي
خطه سلام من عشر نقاط نحن بحاجه الى
ضمانات امنيه اذا كانوا كذلك فيمكننا ان
نامل في سلام طويل الامد ومستقر
ماذا تقول السيده الاولى اولينا زيلينسكي
للسيدات او نساء العالم العربي هم مقاتلات
مقاومات امهات ناجحات كما النساء
الاوكرانيات طبعا
ماذا تقولين اليوم لكل نساء العالم العربي
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامارات قطر
بحرين العراق سوريا لبنان
كل يعني الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
بغض النظر عن المكان الذي عشنا فيه وحتى
بغض النظر عن دينهن الشيء الرئيسي بالنسبه
لنا هو صحه وحياه اطفالنا وسلامه عائلاتنا
لذلك انا متاكده انهم سيفهمون مشاعري
وعواطف النساء الاوكرانيات التي يعيشن
حاليا هذه الاشهر الرهيبه من الحرب مع
اسرهن انا متاكده من انك تدعمين انا
متاكده من ان كل واحده ستدافع عن نفسها
واطفالها كما تفعل النساء في اوكرانيا
في الختام ماذا تقولين لرؤساء العالم
العربي خصوصا ان اليوم الحرب الاوكرانيه
بمرحله دقيقه جدا
في الواقع لا اريد ان اتحدث كسياسيه فليس
للحق في ذلك وحتى بصفه الدبلوماسيه لكن
بصفه امراه استطيع ان اقول ارجوكم كونوا
حكماء انتخبكم شعبكم لقيادته الى مستقبل
افضل لا يمكن السماح لدوله اقوى باستيعاب
دوله اخرى لمجرد انها تريد ذلك سيبدا هذا
تفاعلا متسلسلا ويمكن ان يشعل الحرائق في
العديد من مناطق العالم لان هناك مناطق
حرجه في كل مكان هذا لا يمكن السماح به
الرجاء اختيار الجانب الصحيح والنظام
العالمي والسلام يعتمدان الان على افعالك
شكرا لك السيده الاولى ولا نازلنسكي على
هذه المقابله الخاصه
وشكرا لك على كل ما تقومين به بكل يعني
هذه الظروف الصعبه
شكرا على وجودك معنا اليوم على شاشه
العربيه من العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه
الخاصه من العاصمه الاوكرانيه بذكرى
السنويه للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه شكرا
لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]